bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 week end vous le
savez comme tous les vendredis nous
revenons sur les moments forts de
l'actualité
culture sport et loisirs avec nous en
plateau aujourd'hui patrice le guen et
thérèse moines et bonjour à vous vous
êtes les organisateurs d'un concert tout
nouveau ce dimanche 30 mars à elancourt
vous nous en direz un petit peu plus
tout à leur avance car nous restons en
musique tout de même puisque nous allons
parler d'une animation assez original
créer de la musique à partir de post it
je ne vous en dis pas plus et je vous
laisse je vous laisse se découvrir ce
reportage d'aurélia debussy et jonathan
vilma bleu pour les clochettes ou encore
rose pour la batterie chaque couleur
correspond à un instrument car ici ce
sont les post it qui crée la musique
ce taux qui tu est un outil de création
musicale interactif développé par
l'association lab 212 un collectif
d'artistes au service du développement
de formes artistiques différentes
installée à la médiathèque du canal à
montigny-le-bretonneux jusqu'au 29 mars
stop it s'inscrit dans la thématique
culturelle de saint quentin en yvelines
inventons demain le principe s'est
positionné donc c'est post-it l'écran
quadrillée en fait sert à avoir une
hauteur de notes différentes puisque la
verticale correspond à la hauteur de la
menthe et l'horizontale correspond comme
une partition en fait au déroulement du
morceau et après le morceau est joué en
boucle on a un écran en fait blanc
sur lequel est projeté un écran
quadrillé différents fin des post-it de
différentes couleurs et en utilise
également un séquenceur informatique et
une caméra en fait c'est grâce à la
caméra qu'on va reconnaître le
positionnement du post it et la couleur
du post-it l'utilisateur intervient en
direct sur sa création en déplaçant
retirant ou ajoutant des post it
une fonction permet d'enregistrer ses
compositions et de les retrouver sur le
site de l'installation
je le disais dans le titre de cette
édition nous sommes aujourd'hui avec
patrice le guen président de la société
les concerts à domicile
vous êtes venu accompagné de thérèse
lemoine et présidente du lions club de
maurepas saint quentin en yvelines
alors vous êtes tous les deux les
initiateurs et les organisateurs du
concert appelé les jeunes pousses et se
déroule ce dimanche au prisme
d'elancourt alors est ce que l'un de
vous déjà peux nous présenter en concert
le concert c'est un concert de deux
jeunes issus des grands conservatoires
et on leur donne la chance de pouvoir se
produire dans une grande salle
oui ce qu'on le remarque c'est que il y
a un nombre fou de jeunes qui ont un
grand talent mais ces jeunes dont les
ignorer leur talent on les ignore
parce qu'il ya des musiciens donc ce que
l'on constate c'est que ces jeunes se
produisent devant leur famille se
produisent devant leurs professeurs dans
le cas de concours ou d'examens
mais ils n'ont jamais l'occasion de se
produire devant un véritable public est
l'objectif de ce concert c'est de leur
offrir à la fois une grande salle
puisque le prisme vaillancourt c'est
quand même une salle prestigieuse
et un vrai public alors parents la
musique et que sont des jeunes qui
jouent de la musique classique du jazz
vous disiez aussi que c'était voilà
rendre accessible peut-être la musique
classique aux jeunes qui sont pas
forcément
alors ça c'est le sait c'est le grand
espoir le grand espoir c'est que en
produisant des très jeunes musiciens
puisqu'ils sont tous moins de 25 ans il
est plus jeune que d'avoir de 17 ans
donc c'est très jeune donc c'est essayer
de 2 comment dire de montech la musique
aussi c'est aussi c'est aussi la
jeunesse la variété du programme aussi
nous permet de on n'est pas dans le cade
institutionnel on a une symphonie ou un
concerto et pleure termine par une
symphonie donc là chacun va se produire
chacun 15 minutes pour se produire si on
va passer de beethova sa chance à
prokofiev 1 le var à puccini etc et non
plus
oui au niveau donc des prix c'est
important aussi
l'intégralité des bénéfices sera
reversée aux musiciens sous forme de
prix ce que nous en dire un peu plus sur
ses prix il arrange
oui tout à fait il y aura un jury de
professionnels c'est l'idée de ce
concert et déchets patrice
lors d'un concert à domicile qui la zone
est chez lui et nous nous sommes dit
pourquoi pas offrir assez des jeunes
gens des jeunes artistes un large public
un plus large public
donc il y aura des prix il y a un prix
lors de ce concert d'orgue de ce concert
à domicile il y avait chez nous aussi un
ami un ami qui était enchanté à l'idée
en fait de ce concert il nous a quittés
et on fera un prix le prix guy rollès
spécialement pour lui également
il y aura aussi un prix du public voilà
donc le public participera aussi
alarmiste haddad de ce prix donc censé
jouer son rôle alors revenons justement
au point de départ c'est quand même
assez étonnant donc vous vous disais que
c'était des concerts à domicile c'est ça
c'est vous qui avez inventé ce concept
de chez vous c'est un concert qui
existent mais bon je le développe je le
développe chez moi et l'objectif c'est
de le développer et le chai tourde est
en développement chez moi ce que je veux
montrer c'est que organise un concert
c'est si facile
un concert ça peut être quelque chose de
c'est quelque chose de très sympathique
la proximité avec des musiciens c'est
c'est inimaginable parce que j'ai
organisé des concerts ou de musique
difficile
c'est à dire que les gens ne seraient
jamais d'un concert officiel avec des
musiques étaient proposées vous
écouterez ça à la radio pour la grande
majorité vous fermerez le radio boyer et
quand les gens à entendre cette musique
vivante jouer donc je parlais de la
musique contemporaine quand les gens à
entendre cette musique vente joués par
des musiciens de vente eux ils sont
ébahis et sont tous passionnés par ça et
alors qui sont ces jeunes d'où ils
viennent alors les gens qui vont les
jeunes qui vont se produire donc la base
je vous ai dis donc comme thérèse l'a
dit c'est une
donc deux jeunes qui sont produits à la
maison il ya deux ans déjà donc qu'à
midi lé pa et sabine poucet qui en
passer une annonce dans un journal
on m'a dit on va t elle un jour j'ai
reçu un ami qui me dit patrice j'ai vu
une petite annonce
tu peux pas faire quelque chose pour eux
donc j'ai appelé j'ai répondu à la
petite annonce en disant dégoûté je vous
invite à la maison et ses jeunes la voir
se produire dimanche aux prises
maintenant que c'est à la quinzaine
alors les autres voilà donc après donc
bah on a essayé de contacter des
professeurs dont des des amis que l'on
avait et cetera est-ce que tu connais
que voilà et comme ça donc on va
constituer un réseau et on a vite été
obligé d'arrêter ce réseau parce que ils
demandent qui est extraordinaire ils
veulent
il est midi les jeunes ils veulent jouer
et il faut le jouer alors ils veulent
jouer donc on va re préciser le type de
musique donc c'est de la musique
classique du jazz ont quel type
d'instrument on pourra trouver alors
piano violon un instrument original
parce que donc on n'a pas l'habitude de
l'entendre en soliste on l'attend
toujours dans une formation orchestrale
c'est le hautbois et puis il y aura deux
deux chanteuses de soprane et on
terminera par part d un groupe de jazz
et swing qui est issu d'une école de
musique de l'école de musique de jazz et
de danse à boulogne alors terrain se
voyait donc à travers ce concert donc je
le rappelle vous êtes la présidente du
lions club de maurepas saint quentin en
yvelines
elle vous rappeler à travers ce concert
l'engagement pas seulement humanitaire
mais aussi culturelle du lion ce club
oui querelles et humaniste en fait le
côté humanitaire effectivement est
davantage connue du grand public et
tendre la main vers ceux qui veulent
s'élever c'est un parti humaniste que
nous allons développer donc nous tendons
la main à ces jeunes gens vont pas
oublier que nous sommes des bénévoles
quand patrice se dit c'est facile
d'organiser un concert un concert à
domicile mais on l'a vu quand même que
organiser un cancer de cette ampleur ça
nécessite quand même beaucoup beaucoup
d'énergie surtout posé pour des
bénévoles
et alors quoi est il si
original ce concert si vous deviez
invité les gens pourquoi les gens
devraient venir
qu'est ce que vous auriez envie de leur
dire si la jeunesse qu'on en fasse la
jeunesse et vous allez en face peut être
des artistes qui seront les grands
artistes de demain
là ils sont issus de grands
conservatoires donc certains sont issus
de maurepas de versailles de paris de
quoi centre de paris d'autres jeunes
sont issus du conservatoire de genève 4
3 3 jeunes artistes qui se déplacent de
genève on venir jouer pour vous dire
cette envie de jouer qui est
extraordinaire donc voilà c'est
peut-être des artistes des grands
artistes de demain je vois les
encourager ça on ignore aujourd'hui mais
ils ont tous tous les talents on les a
entendus ils ont tous les talents
possibles imaginables
donc il faut leur donner cette place
cette chance de se produire
vous pensez que la musique classique
encore besoin d'être poussés d'être mise
en avant aujourd'hui ou surtout auprès
des jeunes je crois de plus en plus je
crois de plus en plus j'ai vu une étude
récemment qui qui à la fois positif et
négatif c'est à dire que les grands
compositeurs sont plus reconnu qu'il y
avait un temps aujourd'hui ils sont
beaucoup moins reconnus par les jeunes
de moins de 40 ans ont moins de 30 ans
c'est quasiment ignorés probablement
qu'il ya quelque chose c'est quelque
chose à faire vous avez parlé d'un jury
mais c'est important de rappeler c'est
pas un concours à l'objectif principal
n'est pas là c'est l'objectif c'est de
10 euros c'est de redistribuer la
recette des entrées aux jeunes combats
lundi l'idée sous deux secondes pour
gérer ce genre de sous forme de prix et
nous essaierons aussi mais de rémunérés
en partie ces jeunes gens en fait
puisque ils viennent de manière bénévole
et qui ont quand même des frais pour
arriver jusqu'ici notamment ceux qui
viennent de genève donc plus il ya le
public et mieux on pourra les les
rémunérés et compenser leurs frais
d'accord nous avons constitué un public
comment dire un jury de professionnels
donc tous thérèse de ladite valeur c'est
valérie jose qui est chef
de l'ensemble vocal de saint quentin qui
président d'honneur du du concert et qui
va driver le jury constitué uniquement
de professionnels très bien et bien si
vous êtes intéressés par ces jeunes
talents rendez vous donc maintenant ce
dimanche 30 mars au prisme d'elancourt
toutes les informations s'affichent en
bas de votre écran
merci à vous d'être venu merci je viens
te remercie convoi alors direction du en
cours maintenant dans le cadre de la
nouvelle édition du temps des femmes la
ville présente l'exposition héroïne
jusqu'au 11 mai à travers l'histoire
l'art contemporain ou encore la bande
dessinée la représentation féminine du
héros est explorée dans toute sa
diversité
aurélia de lui si elodie moines catwoman
eve soeur emmanuelle des femmes des
héroïnes qui ont marqué notre imaginaire
mais qui réellement cette héroïne qui
fascine tant
car trois parties on va dire dans cette
exposition une première partie qui est
plus documentaire historique aux montres
en fait d
des femmes qui ont marqué l'histoire il
ya ensuite un deuxième espace qu'est
l'espace principal de l'exposition qui
est consacrée à l'art contemporain avec
dont des oeuvres d'artistes qui ont
réfléchi travaillé dont sur la notion de
représentation de la femme
et puis la troisième partie dans
laquelle on se trouve et une partie
consacrée à la bande dessinée
douze artistes français et étrangers
exposé ici leurs oeuvres
12 vision de l'héroïne pour la
photographe sandrine helberg celle ci a
une double vie je présente ici en fait
un travail qui s'appelle paris burlesque
qui concerne en fait des photographies
de femmes qui se produisent sur scène
dans des cabarets parisiens
en fait j'ai décidé de les photographier
chez elle dans un univers quotidien dans
leurs costumes de scène ce qui
m'intéressait vraiment c'est de mélanger
cet univers quotidien de leur
appartement à paris avec justement ce
costume et 7 ce personnage que sont
créés pour la scène à quelques mètres
une étrange pièce attire l'attention du
visiteur très vite
celui ci se laisse transporter par une
mélodie qu'il connaît par coeur je
présente une pièce qui s'appelle happy
days et muscat président on entend
derrière moi et qui ont fait chanter par
cette sculpture un peu spectacle
titubant qui
en hommage à marilyn monroe et c'est
toute cette époque en fait de mon
merveilleux du rêve américain qui
s'écoule un petit peu c'est marilyn dans
tout ça sa faiblesse à l'une à
réhabiliter ces moments là où l'héroïne
peut-être bascule qui m'intéressent
document peut-être le public sera
dérouté par la vision de l'artiste femme
de fiction d'une autre époque où comme
du quotidien il appartient à chacun de
choisir laquelle mérite réellement le
titre déroule samedi 12 avril la
batterie à guyancourt reçoit le chanteur
de reggae tiken jah fakoly ce retour sur
la scène musicale est marquée par la
sortie d'un tout nouvel album
nicolas gervais la rencontre et voici un
extrait de leur entretien
nous on fait du reggae africain
quand nous faisons duriez aujourd'hui il
est important qu'on prouve que
effectivement que l'afrique est la
source du reggae donc voilà c'est
pourquoi on utilise souvent comme la
kora le balafon qui est un peu le violon
traditionnel en a fait il ya une dizaine
de ciment traditionnel qui a été
utilisée dans ce talent d'un son
prochain album
oui
il s'est baladé
jan fabre l'indiqué c'est un titre qui
s'appelle diaspora donc un message qu'on
adresse à la diaspora africaine dans le
monde pour leur rappeler que dans les
années 50 ou de 50 à 70 la connexion
entre la diaspora africaine dans le
monde et ceux qui menaient le combat
c'est le continent a été a été
déterminant dans la libération du
continent africain aujourd'hui dans la
maison que notre diaspora elle est plus
concentré sur l'économie elle est plus
en train de chercher l'argent pour aller
investi c'est bien mais on souhaite
qu'ils s'engagent aussi politiquement
donc patrice qui a été invité sur le
titre thomas de confusion voilà qui
parle de dépollution et puis il ya aussi
les cas qui est invité sur le titre
human fink chante en anglais aussi je
pense que c'était devenu toute façon
indispensable en accueillait parce que
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance d'avoir une
carrière qui commence à être vraiment
voilà mondial mais ça devient
indispensable parce que le message il
doit aller partout dans le monde doit
arrêt
et vous pouvez également bien évidemment
retrouver l'intégralité de cet entretien
sur le site de tv fil 78 à guyancourt
toujours l'hôtel de ville accueille
jusqu'au 3 avril le salon réflexe
entièrement consacré à la photographie
et à la création numérique
l'occasion pour les amateurs de
participer à un concours gratuit est
d'exposer ses plus belles oeuvres
aurélia debussy et patrick et sacs de
dixmude troisième année de rendez vous
pour les amateurs de photographie et de
création numérique le salon réflexe
organisé par la ville de guyancourt
expose ses oeuvres jusqu'au 3 avril à la
mezzanine de l'hôtel de ville
réflexe en fait c'est la place de
l'amateur dans la création et la
photographie donc c'est un salon qui a
été comme vous l'avez dit à trois ans en
deux volonté de pouvoir faire participer
les amateurs de lui en cours mais
également hors du en cours pouvoir
exposer d'avoir un temps d'exposition
pour montrer leurs créations avant
d'être exposé les créations sont
sélectionnés par un jury de
professionnels au total 38 oeuvres ont
été retenues pour participer au concours
trois catégories sont représentées
photographies noir et blanc couleurs ou
encore création numérique à l'occasion
du vernissage le 27 mars
le jury décernera 4 pris un par
catégorie et le coup de coeur du jury
enfin un dernier dédié à la sélection du
public sera également remis ce jour là
les votes sont d'ores et déjà ouverts à
tous il vient d'entrer dans la légende
du cyclisme sur piste
le nouvel hymne y montrent un a décroché
trois titres de champion du monde joe
cole en colombie mais signe là un triplé
historique et inédit
notre journaliste anthony rech je la
rencontrais voici un extrait de leur
entretien
françois bonjour merci de nous recevoir
et de prendre quelques minutes dans
votre emploi du temps je sais qui est
très chargé en ce moment tout d'abord
première question quand on voit les
trois médailles sur votre genou que vous
avez ramené de la colombie et de cali
j'imagine qu'il n'y a qu'un seul mot ses
félicitations et bravo
ouais merci bah oui forcément
à trois médailles d'or c'est un triplé
unique puisque je suis premier de
l'histoire de mon sport a gagné les
trois épreuves individuelles
donc j'avais annoncé avant de partir
c'était mon objectif
j'ai réussi à le faire et ça peut être
une chose simple forcément basse et
forcément je suis super content vous le
disiez vous avez fait vous avez réalisé
un exploit unique et justement vous
l'avions annoncé il ya quelques semaines
quelques mois
ça devait trotter dans votre tête de
vous dire si je n'y arrive pas non non
ça ne t'ai pas dans ma tête ça ne
m'était pas forcément la pression
supplémentaire oui j'avais annoncé les
semaines avant c'était mon objectif
il faut se donner des objectifs surtout
pas un championnat du monde mais j'ai
annoncé parce que j'y croyais et
forcément déjà quand on y croit c'est
beaucoup plus facile
en tout cas il ya une partie du chemin
est fait voilà c'est ça donc
mais c'est pas parce que j'avais annoncé
que ça me mettait de la pression
supplémentaire
maintenant ça je sais exactement comment
bien gérer mes émotions et et mon stress
que je n'ai quasiment presque plus donc
non non c'est aucun stress
supplémentaire parce que j'avais annoncé
les semaines avant les deux vous
conscient d'être rentré dans la légende
de votre sport parce que jamais aucun
cycliste auparavant on avait réussi ce
grand chelem des épreuves du sprint en
une même compétition remporter les trois
titres
oui c'est incroyable alors non je m'en
rends pas forcément compte encore ce qui
me fait me rendre compte de peut-être un
peu quand même c'est toutes les
sollicitations médiatiques à la
fédération et m'ont dit qu'ils n'avaient
jamais vu ça par le passé donc forcément
c'est un triplé unique puisque je suis
premier à l'avoir fait dans mon sport
les trois épreuves individuelles
aujourd'hui je mens pas forcément encore
compte il ya une image qui me vient en
tête c'est quand vous remportez votre
troisième titre
il ya deux images même vous embrasser la
piste et puis vous vous allongez dessus
à quoi vous pensez à ce moment là bas
c'était juste pour quelque part remercié
public parce que j'embrasse leur piste
donc il était très chaleureux c'était un
public d'en faire il encouragé tout le
monde moi je me suis vraiment senti
porté parce que j'ai été plusieurs fois
là bas j'ai beaucoup gagné là bas avant
de avant d'aller pour ce championnat du
monde là le mexique c'est pas loin
ils ont beaucoup entendu parler de mes
deux records du monde dont qui
m'annonçait tout le temps comme l'homme
le plus rapide du monde
à chaque fois je monte en piste ont
forcément le public il m'encourageait
plus facilement que qu'un coureur lambda
donc j'ai eu ça pour moi c'est une force
supplémentaire forcément des petits
bisous sur la piste voilà c'était parce
que pour remercier public quelque part
remercié la piste de m'avoir apporté ce
qu'elle à ce qu'elle m'a apporté
et puis après je me suis allongé parce
que voilà je voulais je voulais savourer
ce moment là et puis j'avais vraiment
même pas de prétention de pouvoir le
gagner
bon je vais pas rappeler tout nouveau
tout votre cv mais il ya deux records du
monde aussi que vous détenez vous vous
sentez imbattable à l'heure actuelle ou
voilà c'est pas du tout dans votre tête
ça je me sens je me sens très fort c'est
sûr j'ai énormément de confiance
personne n'est imbattable personnes
matin mais aujourd'hui physiquement et
mentalement et tactiquement on va dire
je suis très très fort après je peux me
faire battre tactique mois mai puis le
physique ça peut aussi a dégringolé
c'est très dur dans un sport de très
haut niveau d'être d'arriver au top du
top le jour j
même si avec nous le
l'école du sprint français on sait
comment faire parce qu'on à tourner le
chrono qui est là qui parle et on sait
s'adapter aux chronos mais une grande
confiance en moi j'ai une grande
confiance en moi voilà et si vous voulez
visionner cette interview dans son
intégralité rendez vous également sur le
site de tv fil 78 vendredi 28 mars à
20h45 qu'au cinéma
les yeux d'elsa à saint cyr l'école sera
projeté au bord du monde un documentaire
de klaus d'excel que qui donne la parole
à ceux que l'on voit mais que l'on
entend jamais le réalisateur a suivi
pendant un an une dizaine de sans abri à
paris
quelle est leur regard sur le monde un
documentaire bouleversant et humaniste
sur fond de décor dans paris carte
postale
ça ça m'a fait plaisir
le gaye sarr était là en voiture m'a dit
j'ai des courses programmées deux sacs
on m'a dit ça c'est un monde à part de
ma femme ça c'est nada part de ma
belle-mère pratiquement toujours je fus
je fus la revue de presse de 3,6
journaux tout ce qui est scientifique
tout ce qui est social social justice
violations des droits de l'homme à 60
balais je suis en train de remonter la
pente
retrouvez primer sur les mauvaises
choses il peut encore y avoir les belles
choses
qu'est ce qui nous fait quand vous avez
froid je grelotte
notre quatre ans il ya des matins je me
lève et j'en ai vraiment marre à fond
chaque fois qu'elle le marathon de paris
qui secours moi je cours la mare à fond
paris si on pouvait vraiment se mettre
quelque part mais on dérange toujours
j'ai comme s'il ne considérons pas ce
que tu es là tout est fini pour toi
c'est même plus la peine nous avons fait
un peu la peine d'écouter l'amour
réponse au problème du nous maintient
ici c'est ça le pied
allez on termine cette édition avec
votre traditionnel agenda du week end
versailles célèbre le retour du
printemps avec sa sixième édition
d'esprit jardin plus de 8000 visiteurs
et une soixantaine d'exposants sont
attendus pour cet événement qui célèbre
l'art des jardins et la culture des
paysages vous avez tout le week end pour
en profiter ça dure tout le week end
également l'eco trail le 2 paris un
parcours de 80 km jusqu'à la tour eiffel
pour la septième année consécutive top
départ à la base de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
plusieurs distances sont proposées les
premiers de départs se font samedi dès
10 heures
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous donne rendez-vous
lundi prochain en direct dès 18 heures
d'ici là je vous souhaite un excellent
week-end sur téléphiles